hello hi yeah what's your name my name
is Eileen Eileen yeah
I'm guessing with Marlon I'm from Gary
jail for the north of the country okay
and you live there were here story here
I live over there
Oh what are you doing costume design
awesome interpretation okay there will
be subtitles on Friday no costume
interpretation if that costume design
isn't it fancy fancy
it's fancier Frank okay off you go
right so lead-up to Christmas I was back
home and did you get any of it Chris I'm
thinking about Christmas yeah Christmas
that's the only good detail so far let's
pick out words you'll follow the story
say blah blah blah Christmas blah blah
home into a shop and I had to get milk
and bread
[Applause]
so I was like rollin all right get the
groceries let's go told my boyfriend's
do lap and just pick me up nuni they
park the car so as planned
iq Moy you know perfect attainment
silver people carry are just casually
drift by casual speed so without
hesitation I spread the cross when we
look we made groceries jump in the
backyard screaming and dump in the back
of the chair show them taking a mind
games Christmas and I had like a scarf
up here
which was my boyfriend turned out to be
this middle-aged like six year old woman
push their fertile neck cellar
[Applause]
[Music]
you